hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong mark sir it's
good to be back it's good to see you it
is good to be back and what a movie to
talk about this week i'm actually
thrilled that i get a break from life
because i was up in seattle and the
shows were great crowds were awesome and
i got a lot of people coming up to me
after the show saying that they love
listening to our program which was nice
so now jack when i get back into la and
i'm in the throes of two things one i'm
doing the taxes for my company and the
other one is i'm driving molly the
wonder dog around to every paw
specialist in southern california making
sure that we get her wing healed i think
we're on i think we're on the path to
recovery but this is going to be a great
break for what i have been dealing with
the last month yeah dude definitely um
get well soon to molly but i do
appreciate both between you and molly's
mom like the joint
worried parent instagram posts which
literally make me feel very good because
i look at my dog all the time like why
did i get you i essentially purchased
not really but i adopted something with
the sole ability to destroy me which is
a weird thing about being a dog owner
like you brought something in your life
that can literally destroy you yeah that
will destroy you and your wallet so it's
just a nice reinforcement that i should
never procreate and you know you know
what's interesting about this whole
thing coming full circle is that i was
up in seattle last week when we did the
suicide squad episode and seattle would
have been a great location to do this
episode because i don't know how close i
am to forks washington i don't even know
if force washington exists but it would
have been fun for me to go to forks and
try to like do some location scouting
and maybe be at the high school where
this movie takes place well let me be
the one to tell you that forks does
exist so does the house from this movie
for folks that can't tell if you weren't
up on you know early 2000s romance
novels and you know allegories about
abstinence we're talking twilight kids
and i want to give a fan shout out to
annalise smith she was a fan of our
earlier vampire episodes and she
requested that this one join our list um
she wants to know for team edward or
team jacob i know we're gonna discuss
that
kind of on the opinion that maybe we
shouldn't be team either but let's break
it down we're talking twilight came out
in 2008 it is a 49 rotten score on the
tomato meter but it has a 73 fresh
audience score it's a big old disparity
the fans have said that they like it
critics not so much and to break it down
and discuss whether or not rotten
tomatoes is wrong we have her back
that's seth sabra she's the host of the
world girls and scn and she loves
vampires um i think werewolves too i
don't know steph let us know is rotten
tomatoes wrong about twilight
rotten tomatoes is so wrong about about
twilight this was not just a moment this
was an absolute movement that continued
an entire
franchise sometimes it's not about the
dust the journey it's about the
destination it's not about how every
bite tastes to taste that the aftertaste
and the aftertaste of twilight is iconic
everything about this movie's iconic
which is why 49 is a travesty it
deserves to be fresh
yeah hey i'm not going to disagree with
you that this was the beginning of a
very long journey i think it was 4.2
billion dollars at the box office by the
time it was all said and done but you
know what
let's let's just start with where we
start
the first iteration twilight and mark if
you can please sir break down for us the
plot of this 2008 romantic sci-fi
i would i want to say trope but let's
just say adventure
venture and that's a great word for it
because bella swan is going on an
adventure from arizona where it's hot
and sunny
to forks washington which i hear does
exist and it's rainy and it's damp and
it's moist and it's cold bella shows up
to her dad's place with her only friend
a cactus and then she starts going to
high school and she's trying to make
some friends she gets in a nice little
click but there's this guy
edward and he's part of this family the
cohen's and they're just sort of
outcasts they stick to themselves they
have their dad's a very prominent doctor
in town and then she ends up getting in
a situation where hey maybe this edward
is interesting and maybe this edward
doesn't like me or maybe he really likes
me i can't really tell what's going on
with this eddie in the meantime she also
reconnects with jacob who she knew from
way way way back and that's going to
play in later in the franchise but for
right now for this movie we primarily
stick with bella being intrigued by
edward and who he is well it turns out
get this he's a
vampire yep he is a vampire he's a blood
sucker he
glows in the sunlight doesn't doesn't
melt doesn't turn into newspaper like
you're christopher lee dracula but he is
a vampire and so he has these great
abilities and some limitations and she
ends up falling for
edward all the while we have this
mysterious presence that is terrorizing
some of the folks in forks washington
we're trying to get to the bottom of it
is it the cullens is it other vampires
is it something going on with jacob and
his crew who the hell is doing these
evil deeds and who is going to fall in
love first is it going to be bell with
edward is going to be jacob with bella
is going to be jacob with edward is
going to be both of them with bella is
it going to be bella's dad meeting
somebody god forbid there's a whole lot
going on in twilight and that's why
there is probably such a big disparity
between
the tomato meter and the audience score
for this movie the audience seems to
really enjoy it the critics maybe not so
much which side are we on that's why
we're here wow i will give it up for you
mark you gave way more plot and depth to
this movie than i think even stephanie
meyers who wrote the original book would
if i was doing the synopsis i would have
been like girl too stupid to live who
blinks a lot falls in love with a
vampire and nearly dies that would be it
for me i wanted to be fair to both you
and to steph who yeah i still have this
conspiracy theory that our fan annalise
is actually steph sabra's pen name
yeah i mean i feel like my whole life
added up to this moment high school
stuff would have been like the fact that
you're doing this stuff is such an
accomplishment but by the way i meant to
tell you guys that i watched you all
sleep last night i hope that's okay
god so creepy we're gonna get into the
creep but first um she's mikeless today
but that doesn't mean we can't hear her
uh let's go ahead and say hi to producey
lucy how you doing ma'am oh my gosh i am
so
good
because
i i saw this movie when i was in high
me school things that i've never felt
before and guess what upon re-watching
it last night it recap
the flame has been re-lit
even though i laughed out loud at
certain parts
i'm i'm in love did you read the books
who read the books here i read all the
books definitely yeah but i'm a girl
that like twilight was
very much meek fair for the amount the
kind of romance novels that i read this
is like
you know
yeah this is like tipping your toe into
like fantasy romance i'm like you don't
even know edward as far as we can tell
only has one
uh sexual appendage and the books that i
deal with that is very much the rarity
not the norm we'll get into that in a
little bit but before we do it uh steph
you said that rotten tomatoes is wrong
i'm guessing because you feel more along
with the fans that it should be way
higher um but you know break it down for
us a little bit more why exactly is
rotten tomatoes wrong and more
importantly i think what's interesting
with this one why was it wrong at the
time like because i feel like it was a
movie of its time
yeah i think for why it was wrong at its
time is because it if you look at it
through the lens of it was kind of an
indie project you know what i mean like
no one thought it was going to blow up
it went
it had such a short time between it was
a book to movies and then blew up in a
way that no one could imagine everyone
who read the books felt that way but
then there was people who didn't read
the books who became obsessed with it
but there's just so many things about
this film that everyone remembers and i
think what makes a movie important and
and fresh is if you
remember it like the characters are
iconic it's one of the most iconic love
triangles of all time are you team
edward are you team jacob i can tell so
much about a person what their answer is
and that is because of what that the
romance did it's the most quote one of
the most quotable movies ever i told
lucy before we started this i quote
twilight in almost every single day like
casual conversation it's always relevant
uh the soundtrack was unbelievable ahead
of its time the fact that robert
pattinson had two songs in it and no one
even really knew
oh i knew
well the real fans knew because we're
like is that
robert pattinson
yeah it's really funny i will get into
the thing about this movie that it was
definitely at the height of was my love
affair with robert pattinson which is
not waned necessarily but definitely as
i got older it was a little bit
different so okay i'm down with that
definitely gave me a section it was like
a new sexual awakening where i'm like oh
it was difficult
it was different yeah and then i feel
lastly just the movie somehow was every
single film genre in one it was horror
it was romance it was comedy it was
drama i don't think it meant to be
comedy but to me that hits harder as an
adult and it helps me like the film more
that's fair yeah unintentional laughs
are still laughs uh mark what about you
uh rotten tomatoes is i'm guessing wrong
hey it's all laughs and it's good uh
there there are some some genuine
moments of comedy here too thanks to
some of the supporting cast around the
high school i
on this show historically have said
rotten tomatoes wrong and i say no no
this movie should be way way higher or
way lower and then sometimes i get into
that territory where regardless of a
movie's pressure rotten on the tomato
meter i say it belongs right there at
that spaceball's number 59 which
baseball should be higher but right on
the cusp of fresh but not quite this
movie being in the high 40s
you know jacqueline when i think of
accuracy i think of dan marino in 1984
think of tiger woods in 2000 and i
definitely think of the tomato meter
with this twilight film because it is
exactly where it is supposed to be the
tomato meter has never been more right
than it is with twilight it's not a
horrific movie it's not a fresh movie
there's a lot of enjoyment you can get
out of it and so i think that it is
properly positioned and it also gives
the audience a chance to say no it
should be much higher so it gives them
something to talk and you know it gives
everybody a chance to gab and share
their love of what i will agree with
steph it is an iconic love triangle yeah
it is an iconic love triangle which
let's be honest uh
franchises have uh made their way on a
lot less
than that and so the fact that they were
able to push this through i don't know
this was like really hard for me because
part of me wants to say rotten tomatoes
is wrong because i definitely
loved this movie
but as the other chapters came along i
almost felt bad like oh what have i done
like i very much felt like the dude at
the end of bridge of river kwai like
what did i do like i got really into
this and like was was deep in my tumblr
face with this and now i feel like
twilight oh my god i really i really
feel i was like oh i contributed to this
like i don't know if this is a good
thing and so like it's i have weird
opinions on it so i guess i'd say that
rotten tomatoes is wrong
but
i'm okay with it being wrong how about
that like i think rotten tomatoes is
wrong in my heart but knowing all of the
stuff that happened after this and some
of the really really problematic
relationship tropes that this cemented
in the minds of a lot of pre-teen women
you know what i mean like i'm just like
i was old enough
to like like see this for what it was
when it came out that's why when lucy
was like i was in high school i'm like
shut up
like it's just it's so not cute to hear
you say that because i was i was past i
was
just barely past college but you're
lucky because you didn't get the
impressionable impression
i was in a relationship with someone
that i rationalized their behavior
because i was like i'm bella this is
edward and this is the greatest love
story that's ever started yeah no i had
had
i had already had those sort of like
problematic relationships but mine were
like with movies like can hardly wait so
like i was way past that uh by the time
we get here we're talking like dawson's
creep problematic was my problematic uh
fantasy version of relationships anyway
fell in love with dudes and khakis on
boats
i mean
yeah
yeah
yeah
let's be honest we had fun uh but let's
go ahead and uh remind us where the
critics were back at the time since i'm
reminding myself where i was um with our
favorite segment uh tim ryan our review
creation manager is going to break down
what the critics were saying about this
film back in 2008 in a segment we like
to call two minutes with tim take it
away
all right i'm gonna give you a list of
some stuff right now friends list frank
sinatra elvis presley the beatles the
rolling stones and the jackson five what
do they all have in common teenage girls
were right about them before everybody
else the same thing is happening with
kpop as we speak you know what else
teenage girls were right about the
movies it's hard to imagine now in a
world where everything seems catered to
teenage boys but the earliest and most
passionate fans of films in the 1900s
and 1910s were teenage girls and young
women and there was much tutting and
finger wagging among the pundit class
about how silly those teenage girls and
young women were that they were
absorbing the images on the screen on an
emotional surface level without having
any deeper analysis which is obviously
nonsense and at the same time some of
that was true for twilight which is why
some of the culture-wide snickering that
was directed at it didn't really sit all
that well with me i mean if edward
cullen was good for anything he'd be an
expert eyewitness for all of this stuff
given that he was a teenager for a
hundred years but even if some of the
knocks on twilight were unfair that
doesn't invalidate any criticism of it
and the general feeling among the
critics was that while kristen stewart
and robert pattinson had genuine
chemistry it was all a little bit too
self-serious to work as a whole it's at
49 on the tomato meter with 222 reviews
but it does have a 73 audience score so
what did the critics have to say in a
rotten review genevieve kohlski of the
av club wrote while the movie attempts
to find a compelling middle ground
between gothic supernaturalism and
teenage romance it usually winds up
stumbling into the inane territory
implied by both descriptions however in
a fresh review kim vojnar of movie city
news wrote stuart is a fine talented
actress and she ups the ante
considerably here her strong performance
makes of twilight a far better film than
it would have been with a lesser actress
in the part the rotten tomatoes critics
consensus reads having lost much of its
bite transitioning to the big screen
twilight will please its devoted fans
but do little for the uninitiated as a
final note i want to say that when we
found out that there's a scene in new
moon the novel in which bella's trying
to figure out what movie to go see and
she name checks rotten tomatoes we were
genuinely excited and flattered about
that
i remember this i do remember this
there's a lot of things from the book
that i wish they would have explored
more in the movie but you can't for a
lot of different reasons otherwise it
would just be too long too boring and
too explainy but i i give it up for tim
um
one of the reasons why twilight was
roasted so hard is the same reason why
in sync was roasted the same reason why
all those bands that uh he mentioned
were roasted
teenage girls don't like teenage girls
when they are teenage girls and nobody
else likes them outside of that like
they are just a very easy target because
we are passionate and emotional and get
very excited about things and scream in
high-pitched levels
yeah and
a little annoying and a little annoying
and so like i get it like again as a
teenage girl you didn't even like
teenage girls like no teenage girl was
saying yes this was the greatest time of
my life and nobody was a backstabbing
little heifer around me so i get it um
why anything you know that is teenage
girly is just put in this category of
this sucks
is a really good argument because
also in the same vein the reason why
bella was so attractive to teenage girls
was because bella was just a normal girl
she didn't she wasn't normal in the
sense that no one could no vampire's
powers worked on her but she she did she
wasn't like the cheerleader she wasn't
the most popular she wasn't extroverted
she wasn't highly excelling at school
she was just regular bella and then she
somehow became the star of the movie the
romantic love interest and i think that
resonated with a lot of girls who were
not the most popular not like the most
beautiful
externally
but i get why people get annoyed by
little girls loving a franchise and by
comparison teenage boys i can speak to
this we have it all figured out we
literally have everything solved yeah by
the time we're 15 we get our driver's
permit we're good for life but this is
the thing with teenage boys as as
equally obnoxious as they are
unfortunately there's an entire
generation of men that are older than
them
that are literally about the same
so like
so they kind of get to be lumped into
that it's like oh from about 16 to 35
y'all are interchangeable it's just
whether or not you're staying at home
i'm not saying as far as like who you
are i'm just saying the things you like
the things you do
they're not the patterns of behavior
yeah you all were teenagers and you grew
up to me the modern era of mark ellis
started in 10th grade and we haven't
really evolved past that yet so
i'll keep you posted
exactly and i don't mind them for it
look hey you guys commit and i
appreciate you for it all right so let's
go ahead and talk about all of this a
little bit more in depth let's switch on
over to our movie talk section brian cue
the music
so this is going to be really great
because again i i feel like this is a
moment that i've been i've been studying
for ever since i found my mother's
jackie collins romance novel when i was
seven years old y'all seven i started
reading romance novels and that's way
too young especially if you know
anything about jackie collins but
steph why don't you
like what is it with the sexy
supernatural teen romance because it's
just it's a genre that has kind of been
going on since bram stoker
dracula in a lot of ways which is like
to me one of the very first teen romance
uh paranormal things yeah i i think it's
it's a few things but everyone you know
wants to be a kid in the goonies who
finds the treasure map and goes on
adventure everyone wants to kind of be
the star of their own story and have
something supernatural they want to be
the different one that finds like a
different love story and then i think
that with girls in general there's this
huge fascination since when we were
younger to our whole lives where having
like this
unbelievable unique love experience is
somehow put into our brains as the goal
so then it just mixes so perfectly well
with the supernatural sci-fi
storytelling element because it is
already implementing a different sort of
thing so like what's hotter than robert
pattinson robert pattinson has a
freaking vampire who sparkles with abs
it's just like it's such a good money
maker to mix the two and then uh
obviously sci-fi and fan like these sort
of stories are so enticing in itself and
then when you mix it with romance it's
just it's like crack yeah
i i agree with that there's something
also look at that point in the teenage
girl's progression the idea of something
slightly dangerous
is always appealing like that was like
one of the things like mina harker that
was it she was destined to marry
jonathan she had everything planned out
until the vampire comes into town and
just makes her completely change who she
is and then there's also something that
also like stephanie meyer one of the
things that she did which people don't
key on is she pulled in aspects of
classic novels as far as heroines that
made bella the perfect heroine being
ordinary but someone finding something
extraordinary in you and those are all
things that let's be honest girls that
are way more likely to be found in the
library than the tennis court are going
to resonate with right um i don't know
mark uh did you were you hanging out
with these girls back in in the same
time frame for you or did you were you
did you know this was a thing was it a
thing when you were like in high school
i don't know if i was hanging out with a
girl in high school it was a great day
i
i never i i don't feel cause i was i was
pretty popular in high school because
like i could be the the funny one but it
was never like like very romantic with
anyone and so you would see these
different clicks though and so i kind of
had a bird's eye view of everything and
in my neanderthal brain
it's always more
that the the teenage girl is attracted
to that danger and that bad boy trope
than it would be the other way around
and i think a lot of that has to do with
your expectations that are put on you
from whoever raised you is that they
just want you to meet the the nice boy
the boy down the street the boy who's
gonna go to college and all that stuff
and so everybody has that rebellious
phase and what's more rebellious than
you know dating a vampire so i i think
that's a big part of it but then you
also have that element like one of my
favorite scenes in this movie is when
they lead each other out to the woods
and she sort of is is wise to who edward
cullen actually is and he is just keep
demanding he's like say it say it yes
and yeah
vampire and i think a big reason for
that is because it's also he wants to
hear her acknowledge that she is into
this because it is so mysterious and
different and
mythological and so i think that that's
that's important for both of them to
actually verbalize it so that is one of
the few healthy parts of their
relationship is that their cards are on
the table at that moment it's like hey i
don't go into the woods with a mark
ellis because he's into sports and magic
the gathering i go into the woods with
this guy because he's got a very weird
skin tone and i think he's a
van i can't stress that enough a vampire
and see that's the thing where i'm like
cards are still not on the table because
the reason why that scene still makes me
cringe is because and i remember this
when i saw it in the theater when she's
just like how long have you been 17 and
he says a while
died laughing how old are you
17.
how long have you been 17
a while
it's like wait so your birthday's next
week or yeah it's like a while
and then they continue to make jokes
about like throughout the movie there's
like a few more comments on how he's a
hundred years older and he's like now
you're making it weird i'm like no what
is weird is that it already is your age
absolutely and look and it alludes to
actually another thing which was that
robert pattinson was very much in love
with kristen stewart during this first
movie and she was not 18 for the first
half of filming she turned 18 during the
filming and katherine hardwick the
director threatened him
like she's 17 buddy and you will go to
jail so like i think that's that's
actually really funny what about you
what's your favorite scene steph uh from
the film
oh my gosh there's so many good scenes
but i they're like if you want to talk
about a scene that's kind of
what i liked as a teen because it was
just so
everything about romance is when edward
and bella are now officially dating they
park the volvo which i wanted any guy to
like show up in a volvo i still kind of
do i want someone to whiplash and a
volvo in front of me and they come out
of the car and he's wearing like these
ray-bans and like the whole school is
looking at them and he's like reading
everyone's mind about what they're
saying about them and i just like
remember wanting that to happen so bad
but in terms of actual scenes that i
love i do love when she bella's doing
her research to find out if he's a
vampire goes to the bookstore because
she's not regular she doesn't want to go
prom dress shopping
and then and then is um finds those
creepy men in uh while she's walking
back and they're harassing her like
going to assault her and then all of a
sudden out of nowhere
he whips the volvo out and saves her and
then the entire driveway he's like you
have no idea what they were thinking say
something to distract me hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa where are you going where are
you going
i'm gonna
don't touch me
get in the car
the reason i like this scene was because
even though it's creepy that he was
following her it is like women we live
in fear every single day when we're
walking so to have this guy show up at
the perfect time and then now it's you
go to dinner and you're like so in love
with each other i was just like this
scene is it yeah i will admit to um i
definitely uh enjoy that scene but also
let's talk about it she's still too
stupid to live girl walk with your keys
out in lighted areas actually something
that um somebody noticed was like i i
walk by dog and in our neighborhood
there's like this street and it's like a
busy street and i was walking with
someone like why do you walk down this
street i'm like because as a woman
you're programmed to walk along the
busiest street possible you don't walk
into the neighborhood with no lights you
walk on the street where if somebody
kidnapped you hopefully there's a ring a
video somewhere that they can track you
down like you know charlie is your
father which we haven't mentioned yeah
mark was tweeting about charlie
yesterday because he is the greatest
character in the franchise 100 charlie's
the mvp but charlie's your father he's
setting you up for success what happened
pepper spray
pepper spray i i'm glad steph brought
that scene up too because that's the
scene where people like me going to this
movie like how are you going to fall in
love with a w with a creature with
somebody who could turn into a bat at
any minute who's 100 years older than
you but that scene it's not enough that
that edward sort of rescues bella from
dying because the car was about to hit
her car spins out of control in the high
school parking lot early in the movie
and nobody is close enough to stop this
car to save bella but then edward just
shows up puts his arm out puts a dent in
the car saves her life even that is not
strong enough that's just a reaction the
fact that we see this guy tail her again
a little creepy but save her just in the
nick of time from all these nerdwells
who totally probably live in a town like
that and would do the same thing then we
all buy into that okay he may be a
vampire but he has some sort of code of
chivalry that is rare for a high school
or really any male
100 years old 50 years old that now i
can accept that they might have a
relationship because this guy when you
compare him to all the other townspoken
forks actually doesn't seem that bad
anymore that was exactly right
the car door is for her he does open the
car doors for so nice if you're not
opening the car doors for for a lady
then i don't know what to tell you if
you you should learn that from that
should be part of the learner's permit
test is just have anybody walk over and
and if you don't open the door for them
then you fail they should play that
scene in the dvd
also shout out to that volvo that volvo
was volvo was not the car of uh
teenagers at that time but that volvo
became like a huge seller because of of
this movie
when we talk about my scene it's
actually funny my scene when i was in my
early 20s watching this for the first
time was your scene stuff was definitely
the like them walking up because you
have the girl who would eventually go on
to play selena i think her name was like
christina yes she like takes the picture
she's like oh my god i love that like
that is like such a high school moment
that's like rachel lee cook walking in
for the first time after the makeover
like that's like huge yes
that was my scene back then my scene now
as a 30-something who is looking to
purchase property is the scene when they
get to the house and i'm just like oh
man look at all that natural light man
look at that it's a two-story it's in
wilderness
yeah i was like oh man i want this house
like all i think about now like the
biggest fantasy in 2008 was edward the
biggest fantasy now is that property i'm
like oh i want to lose the cohen
property yeah it's a real place too and
it was owned by like a nike executive
next time that that sounds like uh the
pacific northwest of me next time i go
up there i gotta check it out because
that scene to me also typifies why this
movie is completely ridiculous and does
not deserve to be fresh is
she okay fine
you find out he's a vampire you're
intrigued i get it we all had a phase
like that the fact that this clan of
vampires that has maintained secrecy for
so long because of their clandestine
nature
decides oh well edward has some puppy
love for this one let's bring her over
feed her dinner and just put it all on
the table that yeah we're vampires don't
tell anyone what are we doing cohen's
you're getting soft you're getting lazy
in your old age well this is one thing
that's cleared up better in the books
i'm not gonna say it's not it should be
explained in the movie but it's not the
thing with vampires is apparently once
you meet your person like that's it yeah
like they they don't they don't get
remarried like they don't break up like
it's very rare like because of how they
feel so deeply like once you meet your
person like that's it
and not like imprinting but yes it's and
imprinting is a whole different comment
there's a whole another other day yeah
oh my gosh
creepy
baby in printing anyway so so apparently
as soon as they saw
that she was edward's person and alice
had actually seen them like getting
married her becoming a vampire like all
of these other things they all kind of
had to like accept it that's great they
should have they should have definitely
made that a little bit more clear
because otherwise you're like why it's a
big issue with the movie because we had
time to do cool expository things like
that but instead we had all these weird
shots of edward just staring at bella
and the filmmaking itself is the biggest
hangover this but well besides the
writing because you have two a-list
actors in my opinion robert pattinson
and kristen stewart and they are given
crap for dialogue but they make it work
okay for the most part
i just
there's so many like weird unnecessary
shots that get a lot of those
unintentional laughs you're talking
about like these close-up zooms of
edward like it's martin scorsese making
a student film and it just was so not
necessary as much as maybe some cool
story points like what you're talking
about from the books that didn't make it
into the film
yeah also too i have to get up for
katherine hardwick who's the director of
this she actually directed a really well
a couple great movies lords of dog town
which is the great uh surfer uh sorry
skateboarding movie
that was based off of uh
dog town and z boys the incredible
documentary which basically talked about
southern california skateboarding
culture and the and the guys that were
part of that
but the interesting part that she also
did was 13
which she actually co-wrote with one of
the folks in this one nikki reed and it
really sort of encapsulated in its start
uh evan rachel wood and nikki reed and
the two of them really sort of
encapsulated that very rebellious messy
how you can go from like playing with
barbie dolls one year to like
shoplifting at the mall the next and
that's like very much part of being a
teenage girl
you're talking about my older sister i
mean that's really kind of how that how
that goes down and so
that was i think what got her the job
was that she could understand the sort
of like young girl female psyche
and i just don't think she was set up
for success with this one which we'll
get to when we kind of break down more
of the behind-the-scenes stuff but kevin
hardwick is a very talented director i
just wonder
it's so weird like this movie really was
like an arbitrage around her and
basically the same thing happened with
um
sam taylor when she did 50 shades of
grey we'll get like which we'll talk
about that one um just one more thing
about the scene that i love about the
house i actually liked that they were
watching uh
home cooking like again basically i got
into my old lady about this i'm like oh
they're watching like httv and like the
food network and the house looks like it
could be
like one of those like famous like fancy
houses like i just i want to live there
so that was my favorite scene and
watching
nikki reed's character really hate bella
that was actually one of my favorite
things was just like her being like girl
you are dumb you're gonna end up dinner
and i was kind of with her like yeah
she's definitely gonna end up to be
dinner uh there's there's definitely
some some quotes in this that are
cringe-worthy
uh shout out to mark hoffmeyer he talks
about how the writer of this who
actually also is the showrunner and
writer for jessica jones so like the
woman knows how to write let's be clear
melissa rosenberg i think her name is um
she
wrote this movie and still to this day
despises all of the references to
monkeys because there's the monkey man
in the baseball scene and then there's
also
oh god i can't say it without laughing
it's so good you better you better hold
on
hold on tight spider monkey
yes i didn't know what that was in the
theater i couldn't understand what that
was until i saw it on i was like oh he
really said that
is that one of those quotes that you say
daily from twilight yes
that one for sure and then the say it
out loud i'll say that like all the time
there's so or but the most quotable i'll
have to say is jacob we haven't jacob
jacob's lines like when he's like it's
just a scary story bella like i will sit
and just repeat jacob lines but speaking
of the houses i don't know if you can
airbnb the colon residents but you can
airbnb the swan residents yes and i
think i'm gonna have to do that by the
time i die yeah and forks is a real
place that has had a huge there's like
twilight tours that you can do there's
been a huge like
cottage industry of like twilight heads
in the same way that like people make
pilgrimages to new zealand yeah
but these these girls were making and i
still think there's like a a big
twilight convention that still happens
like fairly regularly fairly regularly
because the twilight kids also there was
another section and i was like right in
the middle of this that was the twy moms
the twy moms were like
older women who were into twilight
like circles that they just like all had
their little yeah but they're
yeah but their kids were too young for
like reading it as a y a novel um these
are the same women that made hunger
games a thing and 50 shades of grey i
might also add because like this is the
other thing about
romance novels you kind of have to keep
up in the ante and it gets progressively
more depressing after each one um let's
see oh yeah
so robert pattinson kristen stewart rob
you said mark that that was great acting
i don't think you're great i said
they're great actors and they they did
as good of a job as they could have with
that dialogue
i i'm gonna say something controversial
i loved kristen stewart as a child actor
she was in panic room she was in this
great lifetime movie called speak about
a young girl that was assaulted she like
i loved her
before the age of 18. i cannot think of
very many films of hers that i've
enjoyed since then and i'm not saying
that she's a bad actress but i have just
not enjoyed any of her choices she
definitely has a specific style
but i feel like this was kind of uh
how cr uh
anakin was directed in star in like all
of the prequels like i think that they
were directed to be a little bit over
dramatic which i think people don't like
necessarily because it's taking itself
too seriously but to your earlier point
about the director and like i think of
13 because i think it's all from bella's
mindset you're living and seeing a life
through an angsty teen and all of the
characters are in that same vein that's
a great point that is a great point and
so that's why maybe you do see more of
those just weird jarring shots of
him just staring at her just being so
weird and disgusted with her and off put
and be that's a great great point steph
i got to rewatch this whole stupid movie
now yeah that would be like do i smell
why are you making that face in class
yeah we're all so insecure when we're
that age that maybe you you are just
you're seeing something that's not
really there you're perceiving something
it may not actually be there yeah um i
will say this uh just to put my
solidification on the acting if you want
to know why i think there's a problem
with the acting look at the final scene
the final scene of the movie which is
actually if you watch the dvd you know
was actually the first thing that they
shot
and
watch watch kristen stewart die
and also watch like
robert pattinson like save her
and like
those are not really dialogue things
those are just them doing what they're
doing when she goes cross-eyed oh my god
i look that girl has talent i am not
trying to say she's not talented but i
just don't know if she's been given a
role that comes up to her and i'm not
thinking that her playing princess diana
in spencer which is going to be released
released later this year is going to be
that movie that's my personal opinion i
have more faith in in battinson
battens in me too i i just have to say
it but their chemistry was undeniable as
i said um also we can thank robert
pattinson for being cast in this
xanax do you all know this story
no robert pattinson because we did this
great video that's actually on
rottentomatoes.com about him and how he
went from sparkle vamp to the dark
knight and in it he um talks about how
he was a horrible auditioner
and he was literally like this is like a
bad audition but he got
got called for a final callback so he's
like hey maybe this will work
so he took a xanax when he did his
chemistry test with kristen stewart and
it allowed him to relax enough and
basically just used his natural
attraction to her
as a way and the scene that they did was
the scene with them in bed
wow and so basically xanax and horniness
is what allowed robert pattinson to be
our edward if not we might have gotten
ben barnes not a bad choice by the way
but that's a beautiful modern love story
what a beginning so the real love
triangle is between pattinson and
stewart and xanax okay yes exactly
um
i have a question though for you guys
like so let's look at this crew
what's her name christina she played
selena
justin shone who plays eric became like
a very accomplished and talented
director who has a new movie coming out
that he directed and starred in called
uh blue bayou he also did [ __ ] and miss
purple he's like a really a becoming
indie director
miss anna kendrick pitch perfect
uh
we got battinson yeah charlie
yeah charlie's angels also christmas
drews has a very like successful career
she's done a lot of stuff since then
maybe not stuff that i've enjoyed but
she's definitely stayed working yeah
dude there's a lot of folks in this that
have gone on to do like some pretty dope
stuff i'm trying to think of anybody
else fully on team as i said bella's dad
i'm i'm fully on that team
because it just i have so much sympathy
for the dude where your daughter who you
just want to be successful and meet
somebody nice brings home a vampire and
then she's like yeah no maybe i'll bring
home a werewolf and it's like can you
just please yeah
are you bringing home the thing from the
black will go now you can can you just
date a nice boy
i know he's leaving and coming back with
like broken arms
too stupid to live that is actually a
trope from books and that's what bella
is too stupid to live she makes poor
decisions y'all i also love uh i thought
anna kendrick was was great she was she
had a lot of the more you know comedic
moments that brought some levity to it
and i thought that was crucial in this
movie and she pulled it off fantastic
yeah hers was my favorite like when
she's talking about edward she's like
yeah like no girls here are pretty
enough for him like i care she does a
great front of me let's give it up for
her like like anna kendrick is a really
really great friend of me and it's great
to mention her too because you know she
went on to do probably one of the
biggest most successful modern musicals
with pitch perfect and for what you will
say about twilight i will give you this
the music in this movie is just really
incredible i think my favorite musical
cue is actually the baseball scene
uh i actually kind of got into muse uh
because of of that scene i thought it
was really good they they did like
starlight and muse became like a
romantic comedy staple they were also
really big in that crazy stupid love
movie
um and apparently that was stephanie
myers that was one of the bands that she
listened to a lot when she was uh
writing this i don't know what are y'all
favorite musical drops from it
definitely robert pattinson's songs i i
just thought the let me sign was so
perfect when she was going cross-eyed i
kind of took you out of that like you
kind of didn't focus on the cross-eyed
and just what was happening
and then paramore at that time yes oh my
god i was a ride or die paramore girl so
when you heard those both of those songs
you just knew it just fits so perfectly
with the scenes yeah
mark what about you i was gonna
reference the the paramore stuff is
really good i think holds up as well as
anything in the movie i did not know
until
i read mark hoffmeyer's awesome research
and i heard you two reinforce it that
robert pattinson was involved with the
music in this movie but um
you know again sometimes all the town
and all the looks are just given to one
person and the rest of us just have to
live with that my skin i've been in the
sunlight it doesn't glow guys
i think i would have a unibrow and he
doesn't thank you
i'm taking that as a compliment wow
wow it is
it is
i feel like that makes you more
biologically advanced yeah
it's the only part of me that does glow
in the sun
it has that vampire glisten
i don't want anybody listening to this
who has not seen mark ellis online or in
the flesh to assume that if he does have
a unibrow he has kept it he's manscaping
it regularly nowadays ladies and
gentlemen i don't believe it uh fake
news uh the one thing i will say about
for me actually because when this came
out
it's very much in my austin
this bar there called the continental
club where you can watch live music in
austin this was definitely a place where
i would literally go out on a thursday
night and just listen to the music and
just and and literally like pick up
people after that this is early days of
like
spotify i think even maybe not spotify
this is like apple music but either way
like downloading music and so you could
really find these up-and-coming bands
and one of the ones that i knew about
was iron and wine they were like a
really big indie band and they did the
last song
um
yeah flightless bird and that one
actually another great soundtrack movie
garden state they're on that one as well
oh garden state does have a great
soundtrack yeah they were on that one as
well and i think that's when i first got
keyed into them let's be honest i i only
listen to movie scores now because
that's the only thing i can listen to
when i'm writing uh but half of the
music that i become in contact with is
from movies like half of it like that's
the only new music i'm being exposed to
is like if somebody does a great needle
drop and there's some great needle drops
in this one i will give it that
um yeah and then robert pattinson
playing the piano and the uh that that
lullaby that he's playing was written by
uh carter burrell who's the composer for
this one but pattinson like heated up
and as someone who is it has mediocre
piano skills let me tell you that is a
lot easier he makes it look a lot easier
than it is i'll say that
um
yeah i think that's it i don't know
stuff do you have anything else you want
to shout out like a favorite scene or a
moment that we didn't get to yet
um i'm trying to think you know the
whole movie to me is like the most
watchable thing i will say if you want
if you want to have like a really good
time i would watch this in a marathon
with your friends and if you don't like
this genre think of it as you roasting
it and you will have the best time ever
there's so many things to comment on but
yeah i did speaking of the prom i really
did like that prom scene at the end i
think that made
a beautiful ending to
the intro of their love story and then i
think what the film did really well was
it set up a sequel in a way that wasn't
forced like if they didn't get the
sequel would have been okay but i did
like you were invested enough in all of
the characters
to um
to be to want a sequel and then i did
read in the prep that was so awesome
with the rotten tomatoes team that alice
was supposed to be japanese that i wish
she was
oh really yeah that would have been but
i loved that um it was what's her name
green
yeah ashley green ashley green she's
awesome she was one of my favorite
characters but that would have been cool
if there was a japanese alice um also
when stephanie mara was writing this i
believe henry cavill was who she wanted
to play
nah uh emmett the big one oh
yeah like i think that was like one of
her her first choices for that i forget
what some of her other choices but i
believe one of them was rachel lee cooke
uh was like i think that was stephanie
meyer's first like choice like when she
was writing this stuff like person that
she had in her mind because you know
they always do that like you know author
fan casting or whatever but by the time
the the show came out all of those
people were like way too old um before
we go ahead and get into um the bigger
thing
because we've got to ask the the burning
question team edward and team jacob
before then is edward the sexiest
vampire for you stuff he's not for me
but he might be for you and since this
was brought upon our love of vampire
genre rotten tomatoes is wrong stuff we
might as well go ahead and clear this up
and i'll let you participate as well
mark because there are plenty of sexy
vampires and i'm sure you could shout
out as well
what about you
well one of them i was a part of this
show for that is a tie with edward
cullen it's kate beckinsale uh celine is
one of the sexiest ever i mean the
we talked about the leather it just was
an unbelievable awakening for the world
but yes i think edward cullen to me is
the sexiest vampire ever because he was
the one that i wanted to be in a
relationship with i was like oh i'm
trying to find an edward now i realize
there's
a lot of time behaviors yeah yeah
there's a lot of toxicity that's what
i'm avoiding edwards now but because of
what he did in my young adulthood life
and now robert pattinson just as an
actor the connection between the
character and the actor make him the
hottest vampire ever for me so that also
puts you on team edward i'm guessing
it's
no like i'm team edward gang all the way
if you're team jacob
there's problems
all right what about you mark sexy's
vampire and then also let me know team
edward team jacob yeah if i can't pick
team charlie then i'll have to figure
out one of those monsters literal
monsters for her to settle down with i
think the the two sexiest vampires in
movie history to me i have a recency
bias but i'm going to say
salma hayek in from dusk till dawn
incredible yes
gonna say it's a remake but it's a great
remake and it's gonna be colin farrell
in fright night oh yeah
i
want to be friends with that vampire he
seems like a really fun hang when he's
not you know sucking your blood because
the guy basically lives like i do like
he comes home he he just moved into this
place and none of the boxes have been
unpacked yet he he just drinks a beer
eats an apple and watches tv late at
night and then he goes out and sucks the
blood you know i mean yeah you know come
on
um
i think i'm on
steph's going to hate this i think that
i do agree with you steph i love that
this movie sets up a sequel and actually
leaving the theater seeing this movie i
was like i kind of want to see what
happens here's why i'm going to stump
for team jacob just in this movie i'm
not counting the sequels because i do
agree that edward was the right one
jacob just in this movie edward cullen
clearly is a head case he's got so much
going on
with his family not to mention his age
hello
and jacob is somebody that has always
looked after bella now he didn't show up
to save her from the nerdy wells and
forks than when she went to the
bookstore but she has a prior knowledge
of who jacob is so she knows that jacob
is a grounded stable guy who's gonna
have his own monster issues but i just
feel like jacob in this particular movie
i would have stuck with the safer choice
and not risked the one that's gonna be
glimmering in all your wedding pics i am
going team jacob and i also have a soft
spot for any
movie werewolf in high school because
michael j fox was a great basketball
player
nice that's a good one um we're gonna
get out of here i'll just say it i'm
team neither i'm team charlie i'm not
even gonna choose either one of these
they're both not great but
hot vampires i'm gonna give one from tv
one from movies um tom hiddleston in
only lovers left alive
very sexy in that one brooding
emo live for it uh and then on tv eric
northman from true blood because oh
that's a good one
listen so hot all right we're gonna go
ahead and close it out on our movie talk
and do a little bit of behind the scenes
here although we talked a lot about a
lot of it already but brian let's go
ahead and
transition over to behind the scenes
[Music]
so like i said we've talked about a lot
of these because it kind of like goes
into this but also i just want to know
who the 5 000 dudes that were up against
robert pattinson
like you know what i mean like this is
some very like you're going to be an
annie type winning like kristen stewart
was attached very early but like i think
everybody else was
was kind of like it came as it came and
she sort of stumped for him i believe so
she's partially responsible for getting
him cast in the movie and like you said
he was going up against ben barnes who i
still think is just one of the most drop
dead gorgeous humans i've ever seen and
i said that when he was prince caspian i
was like who is that guy and why is he
the same species as me i can't compete
with that
uh steph are you
who would you have rather have seen if
there was anybody play edward
i really i i really don't know i like
ben barnes a lot i think he's really
like a fascinating actor which is what i
would have wanted in an edward but when
i read the books and then i saw who they
picked i just feel like it was the
perfect pick especially because of the
chemistry and even if it could have been
acted in a different way i don't think
the movie would part of the reason why
the movie's so good is because it's so
obscure like things work that shouldn't
have worked
obviously the way like how much money it
made in the franchise so yeah i guess
ben barnes would have been a really good
choice but i i'm with robert pattinson
yeah
uh
it's so funny that you mentioned about
uh the one that you could choose and
pick because i just read this i didn't
realize this uh hold tight spider monkey
was pattinson
i did not know that's why he was the
right pick yeah the fighter strike was
going on so melissa the screenwriter was
done working and then catherine was like
there's so much staring i think we need
a line
rob was like i've got one and then they
all went for it and later on melissa the
screenwriter was like i hate that line
they could but she had no control she
didn't get to like oh
well that's really funny she was the
screenwriter i think for almost all of
them
i think she wrote on all of them but was
really funny that she sort of stuck
through because what was really
interesting is
it's very clear that after the success
of this one they were not about
catherine hardwick because she got
replaced very quickly and did not it was
not because she was filming something
else like they were just very much like
we're done with you and it's a thing
that they've done all they also did with
the 50 shades of grey series the first
one was directed by a woman and then
after that they just went to all dudes
and i think it's interesting like once
it becomes the hit
um after the woman director had to fight
with you know a short shooting schedule
horrible resources they were filming
this in like the northeast and
apparently the lack of sun was not
helping them film it whatsoever like all
of those things made it a very difficult
shoot but then once they get more money
in time
let's get bill condon and chris chris
weitz and everybody else in there which
i think is like so unfair like wouldn't
she have liked to had a bigger budget to
do it you know
i agree and i think what she did with
the budget and the circumstances should
have spoken for itself but there was
probably
problems but it sucks because i feel
like this often happens with women
directors is in women in the workplace
in general the qualities that men have
like
they're called ambitious were called
difficult so it just like is an unfair
lens to view her from and i feel like
has she done
many projects since then i mean she's
done a few she did the little weird
riding hood movie um she did something
else so it's not like she hasn't worked
since then i think she's mostly worked
on television since then but it's just
interesting i mean this woman made a
movie that was gangbusters at the box
office
and it seems like she in no way
benefited like um
sam taylor johnson actually talked about
this aaron taylor johnson's wife um and
she directed 50 shades of grey
phone did not ring after that she's like
i have literally the movie that is
lighting up the box office and so many
people have said
one of the reasons why it's even
watchable is because of the great
direction well shot it's well shot
didn't get a job whatsoever it's always
interesting to me it seems like who gets
the credit for the success of films like
this
um and again i think it goes back to
that like do we really respect the
audience that is watching this like do
people just think well these are teenage
girls they're gonna show up no matter
what so we can kind of do what we want
and i do think that there is some some
moments in this movie where i i do think
the the direction wasn't the best but i
can also say that i think some of that
is the behind the scenes tug award that
was going on between katherine hardwick
and nancy meyer who was the author of it
who it was stephanie meyer
excuse me from yeah nancy meyer
nancy meyer don't want to bring her into
this this has got her own problem but i
don't want to like add her in this
like as far back as like the casting of
of this movie um you had a you had a big
tug of war that sometimes she had to
give
more than take and i think that that
makes it tough on any director and that
if you are labeled as if you're a male
director and you're like that more often
than not you get labeled as as
passionate
or
as like a a visionary or a maverick and
if you're a female director you're not
afforded that luxury and so i i give her
a lot of credit for for sticking with it
and and not and and speaking her truth
after the fact because she's on the
record and has been very honest about
her experience both good and bad because
she she did have some some very tough
circumstances to make the movie but she
also talked about how cool it was when
you get introduced at conventions and
stuff like that and you see pattinson
and stewart on stage in front of fans
where it felt like ed sullivan had just
introduced the beatles yeah i will add
this to with the whole katherine
hardwick situation i mean look robert
pattinson almost got fired from the
movie because he wasn't like doing what
he was supposed to do because he was too
serious because in all honesty reading
the book you're like this dude he even
said he's like when i read the book i
went to the author and i was like this
dude is insane like he's weird he wants
to basically fall in love with a
hamburger his favorite hamburger like
how is this dude normal and like to his
point yeah dude rob pattinson wasn't
wrong but he she knew catherine hardwick
knew that was not what this movie was
like he's supposed to be
the you know the heroin type character
he's supposed to be
uh vlad in the last half of bram
stoker's dracula like the charismatic
sort of casanova that's dangerous um so
playing him like a serial killer who
wants to have sex with a hamburger is
not really what he they were going for
um
but i'm curious to you stuff about this
one too because
i don't know man it's it's just weird
looking back on it now like because
stephanie meyers to what mark said
didn't have as much control
as
uh el james did with 50 shades of grey
because folks don't know 50 shades of
grey was based on a fan fiction a bdsm
very very sexualized fan fiction story
with edward and bella
they changed all the names of the
characters for fifty shades of grey but
el james because both of those books
were done on independent the authors had
a lot of say in how they were put on but
el james was even smarter than meyers
she had 100 control over every aspect of
it and i just wonder and it shows and so
like stuff i just wonder if stephanie
myers having read the book would have
had 100 control what do you think would
have been different
i think well mainly with edward i think
that bella was pretty much how i
interpreted bella from the books
and then edward was more charismatic
like he was
instead of making him the he was like
the hot guy he wasn't interested in
anyone and because he was dark and
tortured and brooding and thought he was
a monster it was more that he just
was like in this pretentious family that
kind of just thought they were a little
bit better than people but were
charismatic and like fun so i think that
would have been the biggest difference
and then everything else so in the first
novel i feel like it hit the most
important points that were um and then
presented in the movie but i think
mainly with edward i know that half of
the the girls i was friends with in high
school hated
how edward was portrayed they didn't
like robert pattinson being casted like
my twin sister didn't at first now she
loves it in hindsight and then there was
the me who was like oh i'm so into this
so i think it was mostly with edward
does your twin sister love it in
hindsight because she just came around
on her own or was it the constant
reminders from her
slightly very slightly older sister that
no you gotta look at it through my lens
so did you just get her over to your
cult or did she come to this opinion on
her own
i don't remember and it
however she got there she got there and
she called me this morning she goes this
is the greatest thing you've done as a
host is about to defend the honor
i mean twilight i'm i'm glad that she's
giving you that but also like shade like
no all these other years this is the
best i don't this jaclyn here's the
thing i don't necessarily disagree yes
i've talked about humanitarian issues
and
social equality but then there's
twilight and then it's just like this
huge convergence of everything that got
me to this point
yeah i agree like steph you you champion
a lot of great humanitarian causes but
when you champion a humanitarian cause
you're leaving out vampires and you're
leaving out werewolves what about all of
them what are they what about exactly
and we need and we definitely need to
make sure that that is part of the
record as well okay
that's gonna be it on behind the scenes
which i think we got going we got we got
your twin we got you defending twilight
that was some great that was not just
movie behind the scenes that was us
behind the scenes
this is us i know um
really quick is this is this movie your
own personal brand of heroine
yes
absolutely 100 lucy this is the type of
quote insertion that i'm talking about
jesus that is that is probably those
quotes that she's saying all the time
because let's be honest that definitely
gets the point across um that's it for
us on behind the scenes guys uh let's go
ahead because we still get to open up
our mailbag so let's go ahead and
transition over to the mailbag
[Music]
okay
members of the catch from member of the
ketchup crew
ludovic rubon that is like a great name
right there and i hope i said it right
that's a little vampire yeah
seriously
all right bonjour friends i'm hoping
that he's french uh if you could review
two movies that would be totally awesome
i love them big time and i don't
understand how people dislike them of
course at the end at astra there might
be a little bit too much superhero stuff
unfortunately but besides that it's one
of the best sci-fi movies ever i expect
no less from dune by the way thanks to
the grand dennis so this is about ad
astra which that was brad pitt that was
plan b he plays an astronaut out in
space and i think that one's fresh on
the tomato meter but audiences were not
about that one if i recall correctly
no i saw at astra and i watched like the
first 20 minutes of it that's how i
normally watch anything cause i watch 20
minutes and i'm like i think i'll go
outside and so i i didn't hate it i just
didn't finish it yet and ludovic also
apparently a huge fan of madagascar so
yeah
types of movies but we can do both i'm
up for either one because it's been a
minute since i've seen madagascar and
yeah
i would love an excuse to uh finish that
i was gonna say why did you get next
out of that movie yeah it's fresh though
right it's fresh right
it's fresh so it's 80
it's 83 percent certified fresh with a
rotten audience
is wrong
i remember this one i actually have a
story for this one because i covered
that one pretty heavily on that circuit
and i remember having like
like conversations with award
strategists they're like how is this
like not a thing and i was like
it's the wrong space movie for right now
like it's two 2001 and this is just not
that
like that's not the kind of space movies
people want right now you have guardians
against my favorite quote dragon it's
the wrong space movie it is right now
like that was just not the same economy
seriously though and this economy is
exactly right um
uh ludovic i i i'm down for this and i
didn't get any of your details on
madagascar but hey that's chris rock
as a
as an animal voice so i'm i'm down for
it i'm down for it
steph this was so much fun thank you so
much for joining us today real quick let
us know what you're working on where
folks can find you and if you don't mind
a recommendation ma'am for folks to
maybe watch since you are always in the
know on the best things on our screens
well first of all thank you mark
jacqueline lucy you all are like the
best team ever i it's your show is
amazing and it's even more fun being a
part of it so thank you
for letting me talk about vampires for
an hour
i'm mainly with the whirl girls we give
anything a whirl we do weird things
dorina calls it sexy mr rogers community
all love there on wednesday 6 p.m um and
then set sunday 7 p.m and then all on
the scn network sometimes with mark we
call matches together always a good time
and then i'll say for recommendations uh
dave on fx but you can watch it on hulo
is such an incredible show i love it so
much uh some people aren't as happy with
season two but i swear it gets better so
stay there and then ted lasso and then i
just got the opportunity to watch
suicide squad if y'all feel comfortable
going to theaters i would definitely
check that movie out apparently i need
to give that one a shot i've been
getting like some very like pointed dms
about my i need to give suicide squad a
chance it very much feels like a
girlfriend telling me i need to give an
ex-boyfriend a chance but they're very
they're very forceful so i may take you
up on that one and i may see it in the
theater which goes against what i said
when we did the original suicide squad
but right yeah the ketchup crew has made
their their their feelings known let me
just tell you it's still pretty fresh in
our minds the the last suicide squad
because we did our show on it last week
and so jack and i are going to have to
have a a reckoning when it comes to how
are we going to go watch this movie we
going to go to theaters and see it are
we going to go just at our homes and
enjoy it but probably a couple brewskis
should be had either way because i hear
that it's a lot of fun and it's very
funny so yes and the alamo drafthouse
can make it all happen no matter what um
thanks again steph really really
appreciate you for joining us today it
was so good to break down twilight
because again i do think that you know
points were made we set the record
straight and we've given a little bit of
justice to teen girls uh from the early
2000s it's awesome uh again thank you
all for listening if you want to be like
ludovic and let us know of a movie that
we should review on the show please
email us at rt is wrong at rotten
tomatoes that is rit is wrong at rotten
tomatoes also wherever you are listening
to this follow subscribe rate and review
tell your friends kids we're doing so
much better with podcasts and it's
definitely i know because you guys are
telling folks that they should be
listening and watching wherever they can
so i appreciate that and mark
next week we're switching it up correct
a little bit
a little bit we're still talking about
undead timeless monsters but we're going
to the world of television for
the walking dead
meaning there's a lot of research to do
because i was staying with this show for
a long time i was a big fan of it
haven't been privy at all to the last
few seasons so i have a lot of work
ahead of me but i do it because i care
about our beloved audience which i'm
thrilled to say now involves steph's
slightly younger sister so yeah
he did it also by the way i wish i could
say it's only two seasons i had to start
this very early because the last season
i watched was when they killed glenn
oh come on get back on board there's a
lot of differences i was very upset
about that episode
very upset about that episode yeah that
was it for me but hey i heard it got
better so i'm gonna go back i'm gonna go
back we've got to go back and you guys
will be there when we do it join us here
next week again thank you brian perez
producee lucy my partner in crime mr
mark ellis you can find out where he
will be performing and what he will be
doing at his website mark ellis live or
follow him on twitter mark ellis live
you can find me anywhere at that jaclyn
and also thanks again to our amazing
guests from the world girls steph sabra
and we will see you guys next time on
rotten tomatoes is wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you